bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
faq alors comme c'est la première fois
que je me livre à l'exercice j'espère
que la vidéo va pas être trop longue
à la fin je voudrais commencer par
remercier tous ceux qui ont posé des
questions dans la vidéo d'annonce voilà
il ya eu plus de 1000 commentaires dans
la vidéo d'annonce toutes n'étaient pas
des questions alors évidemment j'ai pas
pu sélectionner tout donc j'ai choisi un
certain nombre de questions il ya
beaucoup de questions qui se recoupaient
je m'excuse par avance auprès de ceux
dont j'ai pas pu retenir la question et
j'essaierai dans la vidéo de répondre
aussi par écrit à un maximum de choses
voilà et bien c'est parti first bas ok
ou vie tu es bien je vis à paris dans le
xiiie arrondissement
bonjour peux tu nous dire quel a été ton
parcours d'études et nous le raconter un
peu oui alors il ya pas mal de questions
sur les études que j'ai fait tard je
vais essayer de vous donner un petit
aperçu
alors vous en serez peut-être douté j'ai
fait des études scientifiques j'ai fait
un bac s
à la suite de ça j'ai fait une prépa
plus tomates et je suis rentré à normale
sup lyon et là j'ai fait plutôt un
cursus physique et puis assez rapidement
physique théorique est donc en fait j'ai
fait ce qui à l'époque s'appelait
licence maîtrise dea dont qui correspond
à ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui l3 m1 et
m2 et donc j'ai fait un dea donc
l'équivalent d'un master recherche en
physique théorique et à la suite de ça
j'ai fait une thèse un doctorat donc qui
vendre trois ans et je les fais en fait
à moitié entre lyon et puis le canada as
tu déjà été au perimeter institute for
theoretical physics à waterloo et ben
oui c'est là que j'ai fait ma thèse
justement alors faut quand même que je
vous raconte un peu ce que c'est que cet
endroit parce que c'est un coin assez
extraordinaire en fait waterloo donc
c'est une ville qui est situé dans
l'ontario près de près de toronto
et c'est là qu'il ya notamment le siège
de blackberry et à l'époque où j'ai
commencé ma thèse le pdg et fondateur de
blackberry qui est un type qui s'appelle
mike lazaridis qui était assez riche à
l'époque on va dire a décidé de donner
150 millions de dollars de sa fortune
personnelle pour créer un institut de
recherche en physique fondamentale dans
lequel il inviterait les chercheurs du
monde entier vous travaillez sur les
grandes questions de l'univers
voilà tout ça et voilà mon directeur de
thèse a été invité là bas à peu près au
moment où je commençais ma thèse et ge
ont donc j'ai eu la chance de faire la
majorité de ma thèse là dans un endroit
assez assez incroyable pourquoi as tu
choisi la gravité quantique pour ton
sujet de thèse et quel autre sujet corée
du prix sinon donc oui mon sujet de test
c'était la gravité quantique plus
précisément la gravité quantique à
boucles et c'était quelque chose sur
lequel j'avais envie de bosser depuis
depuis assez longtemps en tout cas le
problème de de l'unification de la
mécanique quantique et de la relativité
générale
donc ça ça faisait déjà pas mal d'années
que ça ça me turlupinait j'ai eu la
chance de pouvoir aller jusque jusqu'à
poursuivre ce sujet là en thèse si
j'avais pas fait de la gravité quantique
à boucles ben j'aurais probablement
essayer de faire la théorie aux
concurrentes c'est à dire de faire de la
théorie des cordes jeu très content
d'avoir fait de l'apd est d'avoir fait
de la gravité quantique à boucles plutôt
que de la théorie des cordes dans quelle
université as-tu étudier quel était le
sujet précis de ta thèse alors à
l'université j'en ai parlé le sujet
précis de ma thèse eh bien c'était
modèle de mousse de spin pour la gravité
quantique en trois dimensions voilà ta
thèse est elle en accès public et si oui
où la lire ah oui ma thèse est en accès
public elle est sur mon site web qui on
peut la trouver je crois sur les
archives des thèses en ligne si vraiment
vous voulez la lire c'est assez lisible
mais vous pouvez la trouver
ok peut-être le chi premier chapitre est
lisible
as tu déjà parlé qu'à l'astrophysicien
bah ouais du coup quel est le plus gros
coup de bluff que tu es fait dans ta vie
en fait j'ai fait croire à mes abonnés
que j'avais une thèse en physique
théorique alors qu en fait pas du tout
dans le décor comment fais tu pour être
aussi swag ne suis pas compris la
question quelles études as tu fait
et quel métier as-tu exercée par les
étudiants n'ai parlé donc j'ai terminé
mes études par par un doctorat et puis
ensuite pour tout un tas de raisons j'ai
pas voulu continuer dans la recherche
fondamentale
enfin la raison principale c'est que
c'est très très très difficile de
trouver un vrai job permanent en
recherche fondamentale à l'université
surtout quand on travaille dans un sujet
un peu un peu exotique et entre
guillemets inutiles comme l'unification
de la mécanique quantique et la
relativité générale
donc à la fin de mon doctorat en fait
j'ai décidé d'activer mon plan b j'ai
hésité en fait entre devenir enseignant
et puis aller faire de la recherche dans
l'industrie et g soit choisi finalement
d'aller dans l'industrie et à cette
époque je suis rentré donc
chez chez saint gobain qui en fait
toujours la boîte où je bosse
aujourd'hui depuis une douzaine d'années
et je suis rentré en recherche et
développement
d'abord pour faire plutôt des
mathématiques j'ai travaillé pendant
pendant un moment notamment sur les
applications industrielles de
l'intelligence artificielle ou d'une
machine learning et puis ensuite je suis
revenu un peu plus à la physique
je me suis occupé d'un projet qui donc
but était de faire des nouveaux
matériaux super isolant thermique pour
pour isoler les bâtiments
voilà ensuite je suis parti toujours
dans la même boîte chez saint gobain aux
états unis c'est à cette époque là que
j'ai commencé ma chaîne et je suis
revenu il ya à peu près un an et on a
fait toujours je travaille toujours en
recherche et développement
cette fois plutôt dans le domaine du
verre quel est ton métier actuel
alors actuellement en fait je suis
responsable scientifique d'un des
centres de r&d de saint-gobain et donc
voilà c'est un centre qui est située
près de compiègne au nord de paris et
qui travaille sur le vert pour les
bâtiments et puis le verre automobile
comment les collègues et les supérieurs
de ton travail perçoivent son autre
travail sur youtube et 20 globalement
c'est très bien perçu évidemment
beaucoup de gens sont son courant à mon
boulot et ça oui ça plaît plutôt bien il
ya beaucoup de gens qui trouvent ça bien
il y en a qui s'en fichent complètement
c'est leur droit
et puis il y en a toujours quelques-uns
qui se demandent ce que je viens faire à
faire le guignol sur internet mais voilà
globalement ces minoritaires et c'est
c'est plutôt bien vu y compris de ma
hiérarchie donc donc ça se passe plutôt
bien et tu le frère de mic m'acte il n'y
a pas un air de ressemblance avec mark
zuckerberg et tu le frère de mark
zuckerberg et tulle oncle de ligne dans
brink studio alors oui en fait je suis
le fils caché de micmacs et de mark
zuckerberg est ce que tu serais partant
pour me donner des cours particuliers
parce qu'en fait tu es assez canon alors
ça va falloir voir ça avec mon agent
comment t'es venue la passion pour les
sciences et ben j'en sais rien j'ai
l'impression de toujours avoir aimé
aimer les sciences
je pense que ça vient en partie de
probablement de mon père qui lui aussi a
été assez passionné notamment plutôt de
maths mais moi c'est vrai que très tôt
j'ai aimé les petites activités
scientifiques
jouer au petit chimiste voilà à faire
des trucs en électronique etc
donc oui je crois j'ai toujours aimé
aimer les sciences l'espace et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a jamais quittée
voilà y at il eu pour tout un élément
déclencheur de ta passion pour la
science
et si oui lequel discussions cours
découverte applications alors
déclencheur de ma passion pour la
science en général non après en
particulier de ce qui a été mon domaine
de recherche ensuite sur la gravité
quantique
clairement j'ai été beaucoup influencé
par par un livre de stephen hawking une
brève histoire du temps je me souviens
voilà du jour où j'ai acheté ce livre de
dans quelles circonstances je vais lui
et à l'époque je savais que je voulais
je voulais faire de la recherche mais
j'hésitais entre encore entre entre
plusieurs domaines la génétique
m'intéresse c'est pas mal par exemple et
à la fin du livre je me suis d'en
terminer en fait je veux faire je veux
faire de la physique théorique et je
veux comprendre ce qu'il y avait au
premier instant l'univers donc c'est
comme ça que c'est comme ça que séné
d'où te vient cette envie de
vulgarisation scientifique
eh ben c'est un peu la rencontre de
plusieurs choses d'abord du fait que
j'aime la science donc j'ai envie de le
faire partager
et je pense que il ya c'est quelque
chose qui est pas forcément assez
populaire aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de cultures juste pas moi littérature
peinture etc
mais pour beaucoup de gens la science
fait pas partie de la culture et je
pense que c'est important que la culture
scientifique est importante
nous voilà il ya signé assad un côté l
envie de contribuer à ça et puis et puis
je me suis rendu compte en fait
principalement dans le cadre de
de mon métier bas que j'aimais bien
vulgarisé et que c'était quelque chose
que je faisais plutôt bien et que j'aime
l exercice de voile a essayé de trouver
les astuces pédagogique qui vont faire
que on va trouver le truc déclencheur
qui fait que la personne à qui on
s'adresse va comprendre
et voilà du coup je me suis dit pourquoi
pas concilier concilier sages du fait
que j'ai envie de faire connaître la
science en commençant à faire de la
vulgarisation scientifique voilà c'est
comme ça que ça a commencé
quel était ton objectif premier lorsque
tu as lancé cette chaîne à la première
chose qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
en fait quand j'ai lancé la chaîne je
faisais déjà la vulgarisation depuis pas
mal de temps parce que j'ai commencé à
faire de la vulgarisation en 2010 sur un
blog donc j'ai ouvert le blog en août
2010 je crois qu'ils existent toujours
qui s'appelle science étonnante aussi et
c'est seulement quatre cinq ans plus
tard je crois à fin 2014 ou début 2015
que j'ai créé la chaîne donc donc voilà
le l'idée de la vulgarisation sur
internet et elle date de bien viens
d'avoir la chaîne en fait quelque part
je suis enfin je suis d'abord un
blogueur qui s'est mis à faire des
vidéos donc donc pourquoi alors pourquoi
commencer au blog c'est vrai que ça
al'avantage d'être extrêmement facile
n'importe qui demain peut ouvrir un blog
commence à écrire donc à une c'est
quelque chose de très accessible c'est
très facile d'essayer donc ça c'est
quand même le coût d'entrée très faible
et puis après pourquoi pas c'est la
vidéo bas parce que j'ai compris
peut-être un peu tard mais que c'était
que c'était un format extrêmement
puissant je l'avais affronté dans une
conférence à lyon sciences notamment
j'ai mis du temps en feinte avant de
comprendre la puissance du format vidéo
pour moi ça m'a paru pendant longtemps
comme comme quelque chose qui était qui
était compliquée qui prenaient du temps
pour lequel il fallait beaucoup de
moyens et parce que j'étais trop haut
trop en fait marqué par la production
télé qui est très très produite et j'ai
mis du temps avant de comprendre que
finalement ce n'est pas si compliqué que
ça de se lancer en formats vidéos dans
un format un peu un peu vlog on va dire
et puis j'ai mis du temps à comprendre
aussi la puissance pédagogique calais ce
format pourquoi science étonnante alors
bassa date donc ça date de quand j'ai
ouvert le blog est en fait ma première
idée à l'époque quand j'ai créé le blog
je voulais appeler le blog
etonnant non en référence à des proches
pour ceux qui connaissent et puis j'ai
créé mon blog sous wordpress et pas de
bol étonnant non sous wordpress était
était déjà pris je me suis dit merde
faut je trouve quelque chose d'autre
alors je réfléchis bon et voilà c'est
comme ça que je me suis beaucoup allé
science étonnante c'était pas très pas
très sexy pas très ça accroche pas trop
hein mais je me suis bon prince a décrit
le truc et puis et puis voilà je suis
resté je suis resté avec ça quand j'ai
créé la chaîne j'ai pas vraiment voulu
changer de nom donc voilà je reconnais
que c'est pas un nom c'est un nom un peu
placé pas extrêmement accrocheur mais
voilà c'est l'histoire tu maîtrises
quelle langage informatique
hormis javascript alors je ne sais pas
où tu as été pêché que je mettrais des
javascript parce que je ne maîtrise pas
du tout javascript essentiellement parce
qu'on veut dire que je maîtrise mais je
pratique régulièrement de langage qui
sont python et r voilà mais je vais
probablement finir par me limiter à
seulement un python préfères tu ta
chaîne youtube ou ton blog alors cessé
ces deux formats qui sont qui sont assez
différents j'aime vraiment beaucoup les
deux
maintenant j'en fais des choses un peu
différentes je me sers du blog pour soit
complétée les vidéos aller plus loin
j'en parle souvent à la fin des vidéos
soit de temps en temps aussi j'écris sur
le blog des articles sans vidéo qui ont
tendance du coup être un petit peu plus
technique donc donc pour disons pour
raconter de la science à un niveau tel
que j'essaie de le faire c'est en gros
je dis toujours que j'essaie de me
placer à peu près au niveau de deux
niveaux scientifique de lycée je pense
que le format vidéo est clairement plus
efficace maintenant à titre personnel
j'aime bien me creuser les méninges des
fois les de faire des choses un peu plus
un peu plus compliqué ou moi-même
chouchou - au clair et pour ça j'aime
beaucoup le format blog parce que il est
il est aussi beaucoup plus interactif
voilà on parle toujours de youtube comme
étant encore en disant que c'est quelque
chose d'un peu horizontal qui met à
égalité le créateur et sa communauté
mais c'est moins interactifs je trouve
qu'un blog sur un c'est beaucoup plus
facile d'avoir un échange en commentaire
sur un blog que sur youtube notamment
puis c'est beaucoup plus facile aussi de
modifier ce qu'on a écrit donc ça c'est
assez souvent que j'ai des échanges très
constructifs dans les commentaires du
blog qui me permet de modifier des
choses ensuite dans le texte et donc les
à-côtés beaucoup plus vivant la vidéo
c'est un peu un peu figé quand même
d'expérience c'est quoi le plus
valorisant personnellement la recherche
ou la vulgarisation scientifique à ces
deux choses très différentes et les deux
sont vraiment très très valorisant
évidemment quand on fait la
vulgarisation qu'on touche un grand
nombre de gens n'est qu'on a des bons
retours
c'est quelque chose c'est quelque chose
qui est extrêmement valorisant enfin je
suis je suis je suis très très heureux
de ce que je fais est très très heureux
des retours positifs que j'ai etc
la recherche c'est quelque chose de 2,2
qui peut être parfois un peu plus
binaires parce que des fois ça marche
des fois ça marche pas alors moi moi je
suis quelqu'un qui s'amusent beaucoup
d'essayer et même quand ça marche pas je
prends du plaisir à faire la recherche
et à faire la science juste pour vous
donner un exemple
de quelque chose qui est très valorisant
sur le plan personnel je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que j'avais travaillé
pendant un moment pendant trois ans en
fait à essayer de faire des nouveaux
matériaux super isolant thermique pour
les bâtiments mine de rien qu'il ya un
truc super actuelle pas la moitié de
l'énergie qu'on cram en france et c'est
pour chauffer les bâtiments ou 40% et
donc dans le contexte actuel avec tous
les enjeux qui a autour des économies
d'énergie et ben quand on bosse sur un
sujet qui est fabriqué des nouveaux
matériaux super isolant thermique
je peux vous garantir que le matin on à
l'énergie pour se lever pour pour aller
essayer des trucs nouveaux et que le
soir quand on se couche on se dit qu'on
a même si ça n'a pas marché on n'a pas
perdu sa journée quoi donc la recherche
ça peut être extrêmement valorisant
commandes on tue un sens at-on éphémère
existence sur cette terre en perdition
alors qu'est ce que je vais bien pouvoir
répondre à ça non mais ce que je fais là
par exemple à travers à travers la
vulgarisation est clairement un truc qui
donne qui donne du sens c'est quelque
chose qui me tient à coeur dont j'estime
que c'est important
j'ai la chance de pouvoir le faire il
prend du plaisir et que ça marche donc
voilà ça ça ça ça donne un sens comment
décrirais tu ta communauté alors basse
et c'est toujours un peu difficile 1
gd évidemment une perception de la
communauté via les commentaires mais on
sait que que les gens qui commentent
sont vraiment une toute petite minorité
du total et pas forcément toujours une
minorité représentative alors youtube
fournit des statistiques dites
démographique sur notamment les tranches
d'âge de sexe des gens qui regardent
alors c'est assez c'est assez
alors pour les tranches d'âge on se
balade typiquement enfin j'essaierai de
vous mettre les chiffres mais entre
entre 15 et 35 ans il ya un peu de tout
mais par contre d'après les stats de
youtube c'est très très très masculin ça
c'est toujours un peu triste quand on a
un vulgarisateur scientifique parce
qu'il ya un peu ce stéréotype que voilà
la science c'est moins pour les filles
que pour les garçons et c est donc voila
j'aimerais j'aimerais apporter ma toute
petite pierre vous faites de changer un
peu ça donc quand j'ai les commentaires
de filles qui disent qu'elles aiment ce
que je fais je me dis que ça va ça va
toujours un bon sens et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde les stats je sais pas
d'après youtube c'est 90 ou 95% le mec
alors c'est clairement biaisé parce que
pour tout un tas de raisons
voilà si je regarde je crois sur
facebook on est plutôt à 70 30 mais bon
enfin voila je pense qu'on a tous tous
les vulgarisateurs ont un peu ce
problème entre guillemets et voilà je
crois qu'on a tous très envie de lutter
contre ce stéréotype
voilà je suis très content quand là
quand la part féminine de mon audience
augmente
je me demandais si tu es courbe de
rétention sont tout comme celle que tu
as présenté à lyon ou pas alors oui
j'avais présenté à lyon une courbe de
rétention c'est à dire ses courbes qui
montre combien de temps les gens restent
devant la vidéo ou alors par exemple au
bout de cinq minutes de vidéo combien de
gens sont toujours devant par rapport à
ceux qui ont commencé et c'est vraiment
un des trucs qui m'a absolument surpris
mais vraiment surpris sur youtube c'est
quand j'ai vu arriver les premières
courbes de rétention je ne m'attendais
pas à ce que les gens restent autant je
pensais qu'il y avait une érosion voilà
il y avait à la fin toujours
systématiquement 5 % des gens qui
allaient au bout et en fait et en fait
non c'est pas du tout le cas les gens
restent beaucoup ce qui évidemment fait
très plaisir ce
de dire que le fait du bon boulot mais
c'est vraiment ça en fascinant alors
savary ça varie suivant les vidéos des
vidéos plus complexes ou des vidéos plus
longue forcément à la fin et on n'a pas
70 % des gens qui sont là mais
typiquement ça se balade entre soixante
dix et quarante pour cent des gens qui
restent jusqu'au bout et les en fait il
ya un certain nombre de personnes qui
partent au début et après c'est
relativement plat ou en tout cas être
une faible érosion
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose de
surprenant et c'est assez fascinant et
ça fait très plaisir de voir ça bonjour
david je t'ai envoyé un message par mail
il ya quelques semaines est une marque
toujours pas répondu est ce que c'est
parce que tu n'as pas lu ou que tu n'as
pas voulu me répondre
alors oui comme pas mal de gens je
reçois je reçois beaucoup de messages de
sollicitations de change fait j'en suis
très content et malheureusement je n'ai
pas le temps de répondre à tout le monde
j'arrive encore à peu près avoir tous
les commentaires je sais pas du coup je
ne sais pas sur quoi était ton message
en lisant justement non ça ne me dit
rien et j'avoue que je n'ai pas toujours
le temps de répondre à tout le monde
donc voilà soit des sollicitations c'est
vrai sur sur la chaîne bien sûr mais
aussi sur facebook sur twitter par mail
sur tipi sur le blog etc
et donc voilà on n'est pas enfin je dis
non parce que je pense que je suis pas
le seul gary sénateurs est dans cette
situation on n'arrive pas toujours à
répondre à tous notamment un truc où
j'ai tendance à a pas souvent répondre
c'est quand les gens me posent des
questions qui en ferait parfaitement été
en commentaire de la vidéo et donc du
coup j'ai toujours un peu enfin voilà
prendre le temps de faire une réponse
pour qu'un et qu'une personne qui en
profitent c'est pas toujours le plus le
plus tentants donc donc oui j'avoue j'ai
pas toujours
j'arrive pas toujours à répondre à tout
le monde et j'en suis désolé
à quand une rencontre abonnés en
convention alors oui je fais pas
généralement de convention tout cas je
n'ai pas vraiment fait jusqu'ici pour
une bonne raison qu'ils aient qu'en fait
comme je bosse à côté j'ai très peu de
temps donc j'ai jamais trouvé un moment
où j'avais à la fois l'opportunité
d'aller d'aller dans une convention et
où j'étais libre où j'avais l'énergie
etc
donc voilà je perds vraiment fait de
rencontres
abonnés j'espère que ça ne vous manque
pas trop je serai peut-être d'en faire
d'enfer quelques-unes voilà dans les
mois à venir mais c'est vrai que je j'ai
rarement d'occasions de rencontrer ma
communauté
en vrai en rien contribué à démocratiser
le savoir scientifique est il à pécho
lors des événementiels geek
bah du coup j'en sais rien est ce qu on
pourrait te voir un jour présenté une
conférence dans une université française
alors pareil j'ai eu très peu
d'occasions d'aller d'aller présenter
des choses dans des dans des universités
simplement voilà par manque de temps et
de disponibilité
si j'ai l'occasion de le faire j'ai crs
j'essaierai de le faire peut-être plus
proche de de fais moi mais voilà j'ai
pas encore vraiment eu l'occasion le
temps de le faire
penses tu revenir sur rennes alors oui
je reviendrai à rennes en 2017 je sais
plus très bien la date mais je vous la
mettrais je crois que c'est au moins de
février au mois de mars
et donc je reviendrai à l'espace des
sciences pour pour une conférence à 60
conférences ça ne sera pas une interview
comme comme la dernière fois salut tu as
fait plusieurs fois allusion la guyane
dans tes vidéos et apparemment tu y lit
alors pas du tout je pense que je n'ai
jamais parlé de la guyane je n'ai jamais
mis les pieds là à tuer des envies ou
des idées concernant l'évolution future
de la chaîne alors pas de pad idée très
précise en fait je improvise assez
largement je laisse venir
j'ai pas de projet très très très très
précis en tête de faire des trucs très
très différents donc je pense que je
vais continuer un peu sur le sur le
format actuel
voilà j'ai quelques contacts pour
essayer de tester des formats un petit
peu un petit peu différent plus sous
forme reportage ou une interview mais
voilà je me fixe pas à spécialement
d'objectif particulier
et puis peut-être qu'à les nouvelles
choses qui viendront naturellement
penses tu l'as terme de faire que des
vidéos sur youtube
citons succès continue de croître ou
alors juste faire ça de temps en temps
par plaisir mais j'ai plutôt tendance à
vouloir faire ça par plaisir pour tout
un tas de raisons d'abord parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya aujourd'hui pas vraiment
de modèle économique sur youtube qui
permette complètement aux créateurs dans
vivre beaucoup beaucoup font autre chose
à côté
et puis et puis le fait de le faire en
tant que l'oisillon complément a quand
même beaucoup davantage parce que ça met
du coup pas de pression je fais un peu
ce que je veux je me sens pas obligé de
faire traiter des thèmes nous c'est
qu'ils vont être populaire même mois là
fait vraiment ce que je veux je suis
totalement libre et je trouve ça très
bien as tu prévu d'écrire un deuxième
livre
alors oui j'ai prévu plus que prévu en
fait c'est en cours voilà donc suite
suite à mon premier livre mon éditeur
m'a proposé de d'en faire un deuxième
alors je voulais pas vraiment faire un
tome 2 dans le même esprit donc voilà on
a passé un peu de temps à essayer de
trouver un angle qui soit qu'ils soient
un peu un peu intéressant un peu
original et voilà on a trouvé quelque
chose donc j'ai le plan est fait
maintenant fou je commence à écrire tu
as des enfants je crois ce que tu as
comme objectif de faire une série pour
enfants
alors bonne question oui c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qui manque
aujourd'hui un peu peut-être dans le
paysage de la vulgarisation et quelques
chaînes qui font ça très bien je pense à
une chaîne qui s'appelle substratum que
j'adore qui fait pas de la vulgarisation
ses plus proches des cours mais mais
mais je trouve super si j'avais le temps
j'aimerais bien fait un truc pour les
enfants je suis pas sûr que ce soit là
où je sois le meilleur je pense qu à
plein de gens qui feraient ça mieux que
moi mais voilà aujourd'hui j'ai pas
vraiment le temps d'explorer un nouveau
format comme ça mais clairement il ya un
truc à faire autour de la vulgarisation
pour les enfants crois tu que les vidéos
youtube comme les tiennes peuvent être
un moyen de révolutionner la manière
dont on apprend la science aux gens
alors il faut il faut être clair sur un
truc et je pense que la plupart des
vidéastes vulgarisateur vous tiendront
demain discours que moi ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on n'a pas vocation à remplacer
des cours de sciences ont fait de la
vulgarisation c'est à dire que en gros
c'est du domaine de la culture on
saupoudre des trucs voilà on n'a pas
vocation à délivrer un enseignement de
sciences et encore moins à remplacer les
enseignants qui le font donc ça c'est
clair
maintenant je pense qu'effectivement
l'enseignement en général va peut être
évoluer notamment sous l'impulsion de
choses comme voilà les cours en ligne et
je crois beaucoup à des modèles du type
class inversé ou en fait finalement le
cours magistral sera sera vue
en vidéo chez soi et on viendra plus tôt
à l'école pour faire les devoirs ou en
tout cas tout ce qui est plus de l'ordre
du teide etc
donc je pense que là je pense que la
vidéo en ligne va probablement
bouleversé les modes d'enseignement de
cette manière là mais je ne crois pas
que les vulgarisateurs vidéaste vont
remplacer les profs sa chaîne youtube et
on blogue notes ont-ils jamais donné
l'idée de devenir enseignant-chercheur
en université ou en école d'ingé alors
clairement aux congés quand j'ai fini ma
quand j'ai fini ma thèse je m'étais posé
la question de savoir si vu que je
pouvais pas vraiment devenir chercheur
si peut-être pouvait devenir enseignant
alors c'était plutôt plutôt lisse et du
coup à ce moment là elle à devenir
angers enseignant-chercheur en
université ou en école d'ingénieur
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut il faut
être dans le domaine de recherche sur
lequel vont chercher quelqu'un etc
donc voilà c'est l'opportunité s'est
jamais présenté pour moi donc avec la
question s'est pas vraiment posé
quelques projets hors phase calmes dans
des laboratoires oui alors j'ai quelques
discussions avec des labos pour pour
aller justement faire quelque chose qui
soit plus de l'ordre du reportage ou
bien de l'interview et c'est alors la
fois c'est un format qui me tente à la
fois c'est un format qui est compliqué
parce que qui demande tout est beaucoup
plus investissement en termes de
matériel logistique de temps et c'est
donc qui est un peu plus difficile pour
moi alors je pense que j'essaierai d'en
faire un voilà ne serait ce que pour
tester le concept est et je pense
notamment enfin j'ai des discussions
assez intéressante avec avec un labo
soit l'âge princier moyenne fait un truc
vraiment sympa mais je ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure je pousserai le concept
penses tu que la fréquence des vidéos
pourraient être accélérées avec le temps
alors je pense j'ai pas vraiment envie
d'augmenter la fréquence des vidéos
alors là en plus on parle d'accélérer la
fréquence des effets secondaires non
j'ai pas vraiment envie d'augmenter la
fréquence des vidéos
parce que
ça serait trop compliqué à faire
logistiquement aujourd'hui voilà je suis
de l'ordre de vidéos toutes les deux
semaines à peu près est allé au delà de
ça ce serait ça serait trop compliqué je
pense qu'après aussi peut-être pour vous
les spectateurs ça serait ça serait
peut-être ça serait peut-être trop je
pense que voilà une vidéo toutes les
deux semaines c'est un bon rythme à la
fois pour pour vous et pour moi mais
voilà si vous en voulez beaucoup plus
faites le moi savoir
là je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'est dans les conditions actuelles ça
soit ça soit faisable
tu nous offres tout le temps de
merveilleuses vidéo scientifique à
caractère théorique comptes tu faire un
jour une expérience en pratique alors je
fais pas beaucoup d'expérience j'en ai
fait quand même quelques unes j'avais
fait sur le pastis les bulles de savon à
là bas parce que voilà il ya des gens
qui font ça très très bien je vais
évidemment expérimente boy par exemple
mais on ad'autres donc donc voilà les
gens qui font ça très bien moi mon truc
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt la physique
théorique nom domaine de spécialité
donc voilà j'ai plutôt tendance à faire
des choses où je joue je papote plutôt
qu'à faire des manifs mais voilà je vous
crache pas sur en faire une de temps en
temps et s'il ya des idées qui me
viennent ce sera avec plaisir
de nouvelles collaborations en vue après
celle avec eureka très réussi la merci
c'était très sympa de collaborer avec
eureka effectivement alors j'ai pas fait
beaucoup de collaborations je crois en
effet que deux gmsl avec eureka sur le
bitcoin et j'en avais fait une avec
connu sur sur la machine qui invente des
mots la raison c'est qu'en fait je veux
pas faire de la cola but pour faire de
la colle à l'idée c'est de se faire un
truc et du sens donc vraiment ou saas ou
la collaboration se justifie au delà du
plaisir de faire un truc ensemble et du
coup bah voila j'aimerais enfin je les
fais que quand ça se présente est qu'il
ya vraiment un truc qui est qu'il y
avait du sens du coup plutôt dans des
domaines hors de mon domaine de
spécialité enfin que ce soit l'économie
ou bien plutôt la langue donc j'ai
quelques idées qui traîne comme ça
l'idée enfin voilà deux avec des gens
avec qui j'en ai pas d'ailleurs
forcément parler donc voilà j'en ferai
peut-être d'autres ne sais pas je ne
cours pas non plus après après beaucoup
de colère est ce que tu en contact avec
d'autres vidéastes de vulgarisation
scientifique pour éviter une redondance
des sujets alors déjà on est tous en
contact à peu près les uns avec les
autres notamment dans la vulgarisation
scientifique il ya la vidéo science je
vous recommande d'aller sur la page de
vidéos science et on a une petite
mailing-list qui fait que l'on se parle
tous on se connaît tous
sur la redondance des sujets en fait
globalement on s'en fout un peu
je crois que c'est important enfin je
suis je toujours légèrement agacé quand
je reçois des commentaires du genre ah
oui mais non machin on avait déjà parlé
à venir c'est pas grave quoi on a le
droit de parler d'un sujet même si
machin on avait déjà parlé il ya il ya
six mois ou trois ans voilà aucun aucun
vulgarisateur n'est propriétaire
exclusif des sujets qu'ils traitent et
c'est même plutôt bien parce qu'on a
tous d approche un peu différente donc
donc c'est très bien si on est plusieurs
à traiter le même sujet je crois pas du
tout que ça fasse sa phase redondance en
tout cas moi je ne tiens pas compte je
voulais poser une question me suis
obligée de poser celle ci d'abord on
vous voit où on tutoie à zurich
quel âge avait rimbaud il n'était pas né
je crois une passion en dehors des
sciences alors oui plusieurs plusieurs
passions même un jeu fait en tout cas
j'ai fait beaucoup de musique
j'en fais un peu moins aujourd'hui j'en
fais un peu des fois pour la chaîne pour
faire les petits les petit jingle mes
petits seins trop voilà sinon je joue au
badminton
je suis un mordu de jeux de société as
un peu old school à l'heure dé jeu vidéo
mais non moi j'aime bien j'aime bien
faire des jeux de société voilà quelques
quelques exemples de passion qui
m'occupe musicien n'est ce pas un petit
morceau pour la fac
non je vais peut-être pas voulu un
morceau de ce 8 mai mais comme je vous
disais en fait tout ce qui est sûr sur
la chaîne quasiment en fait a été fait
par mois pour une raison qui est que en
fait quand j'ai commencé à vouloir
mettre des musiques etc
c'était pas du tout clair dans ma tête
pour moi les questions de droit de trucs
comme ça même quand c'est des trucs
supposément libre et donc pour patron de
reste je me suis dit je vais tout faire
moi même et puis ça ne s'amusait donc
voilà tout ce que vous entendez
musicalement sauf exceptions auxquelles
cassez précisé sur la chaîne en fait
c'est moi qui l'ait fait et puis si vous
voulez me voir jouer de la guitare je
joue un peu dans l'épisode que j'ai
tourné avec la chaîne string theory sur
l'acoustique raconte nous ton parcours
musical
ben moi j'ai commencé là là par la
guitare en fait quand j'étais quand
j'étais ado parce que je ne suis que
c'était quand même pratique pour draguer
voilà que j'ai fait beaucoup de guitares
principalement principalement assez vite
je me suis mis à faire du rock
progressif qui était visible que jamais
bien
j'ai fait beaucoup aussi de funk dont
j'ai joué dans plein de groupes eux un
peu dansé dansé de style là c'est assez
différent
et puis sur le tard je me suis mis à
apprendre d'autres instruments dont j'ai
appris la basse
j'ai appris un peu la batterie j'ai joué
un peu dans un groupe
voilà les chanter je me suis aussi au
piano en autodidacte donc je suis un
mauvais pianiste mais ça m'amuse
beaucoup
des guitaristes favoris alors
principalement on va dire david gilmour
le guitariste de pink floyd
mark fuller celui de celui de derrière
cette voix là et puis non plus tôt
plutôt les classiques les classiques du
rock
jimmy page flash etc
carlos santana des jeux des gens qui
sont pas forcément toujours les méga
virtuose mais c'est des mecs qui ont un
style quoi il joue n'importe qui les
reconnaît une fois ou deux tu vas parler
des échecs quel est ton lots alors oui
j'ai parlé je crois deux fois des échecs
quand j'ai fait une vidéo sur le poker
et j'en ai fait une sur le go et c'est
marrant je en revoyant celle sur le go
je crois je parle des échecs sur un ton
qui laisse penser que je suis à la fois
connaisseurs et amateurs d'où la
question
imagine sur les lots alors en fait non
pas du tout je suis nul aux échecs et je
déteste les échecs
en fait je n'aime pas parce que parce
que je trouve ça hyper froid il n'y a
pas du tout de 2 à zarzis et pai a pas
de thème
je suis désolé pour tous les gens qui
aiment les échecs un mois c'est juste ma
vie personnelle et du cou du coup les
échecs que dont j'aime pas trop jouer
aux échecs parce que je trouve ça en
plus haut quand on perd comme n'y a pas
de hasard c'est vraiment juste qu'on est
con et plus con claude quoi donc
donc j'ai pas trop les échecs tu es là
je suis un fan de ces jeux de plateau où
il ya où il ya plein de tuyaux partout
où il ya où il ya une part de hasard etc
mais voilà désolé les échecs j'avoue
j'avoue j'aime pas et tu jamais devenu
accro à un jeu vidéo et si oui lequel
alors accro je pense le seul exemple ces
civilisations le 2003 quand j'étais
quand j'étais plus jeune depuis j'évite
d'y rejouer pour éviter de flinguer une
cinquantaine d'heures sinon alors là ça
va parler que aux plus anciens j'ai été
super accroc un jeu d'enquêté policière
qui s'était moqué island sur sur atari
st
le meilleur jeu vidéo de tous les temps
voilà en effet six noms et puis sinon
mario kart est ce que ton tableau
derrière et de jeremy man alors non les
tableaux qu'on voit en fondant les
vidéos j'ai dû en faire un ou deux
différents cd tableau d'un peintre qui
est s'appelle doutreleau est en fait les
deux types de tableau que j'ai mis dans
les vidéos cd des représentations de
l'avenue de new york
voilà j'adore doutreleau j'en ai enfin
j'ai plusieurs reproductions de lui chez
moi il est vraiment un style que j'aime
beaucoup
et donc voilà doutreleau je vous
encourage à aller regarder ce qui fait
niveau lecture s'est quittés écrivains
de chevet je sais pas si j'ai des
écrivains de chevet si je réfléchis à ce
dont je lis tout presque
je pense qu'il y en a deux c'est ken
follett qui fait notamment des romans
historiques qui sont absolument fabuleux
et puis et puis dans le genre polar plus
tôt granger je pense que j'ai dû lire à
peu près tout ce qu'il a fait voilà
sinon il ya plein de trucs que j'aime
mais bon les deux écrivains non vraiment
je lis tous les yeux fermés ces deux là
quel est ton livre préféré ton film
préféré ta série préférée alors livre
bas je pense que peut enfin voilà ça
pourrait être le les piliers de la terre
de ken follett qui est un truc un truc
de malade donc si vous connaissez pas
les piliers de la terre
un roman historique qui se passe ou 11e
siècle en angleterre et qui raconte la
construction des cathédrales séparait
pas sexy comme ça mais c'est juste un
bouquin fabuleux et puis sinon quand
même un livre qui m'a énormément marqué
c'est pas très original mais c'est le
seigneur des anneaux je me revois encore
collégien passons des heures à lire le
seigneur des anneaux ça m'a évidemment
un livre qui est un peu particulier pour
moi comme beaucoup de gens films
préférés
voilà c'est tout y est toujours un peu
du domaine du un peu arbitraire a
décrété qu'un nos films et préférez donc
si je devais en citer un je citerai la
cité des enfants perdus de caro et
jeunet et série préférée c'est pareil
les uns plein de trucs mais
pour citer un truc un peu un peu
original on va dire aux newsgroups
à quoi est-ce que tu ressembles par
derrière on voit que ton visage dans
toutes les vidéos ça il va falloir voir
avec mon agent vous semble être un
touche-à-tout scientifique vos sujets
sont variés parmi les sujets que vous
avez traité en vidéo il y en a t'il que
vous ne connaissiez que peu qu'ils vous
ont demandé des recherches intenses
oui alors évidemment je ne maîtrise pas
de naissance tous les sujets dont je
parle
quand je parle de maths ou de physique
c'est souvent des choses que je connais
voir que je connais bien
quand je parle de bio plus de sciences
sociales forcément c'est des choses qui
que je connais moins bien et qui ne
demande pas mal de travail donc oui je
fais pas mal de recherches sur un
certain nombre de sujets où te procure
tu les documents nécessaires à tes
vidéos en général tu es moyen d'avoir
des sources solides alors la grande
question des sources alors conséquent
c'est un sujet que je connais bien en
général ça peut bien sûr que ça peut
être tout simplement
voilà mes cours de licence ou une
maîtrise après de manière générale pour
traiter un sujet et trouver les bonnes
sources
c'est relativement simple wikipedia est
très bien fait c'est à dire que l'
avantage de wikipédia c'est qu'en
général les articles sont plutôt bien
fait et ça nous pointe quand même quels
sont les grands domaines importants dont
il va falloir au moins qu'il fallait
considérer mais surtout wikipedia ainsi
que les sources et souvent site les
publications scientifiques
donc moi quand je j'attaque un nouveau
sujet sur lequel je suis vraiment pas à
l'aise je pense notamment à tous que
peut raconter en biologie en général je
fais toujours la même chose wikipedia et
je vais lire les articles scientifiques
d'origine devant les publications en
anglais et ou alors c'est un peu c'est
un peu parfois c'est un peu violent
parce que quand on n'est pas du domaine
de recherche
mais c'est vraiment le meilleur moyen
d'être sûr qu'on raconte pas de
conneries donc donc je me sert en fait
de wikipédia comme une source de source
et puis en fait je vais au maximum lire
les articles scientifiques
peux-tu nous partager un peu les
coulisses la préparation l'écriture etc
ça pour inspirer les autres prochain
vulgarisateur scientifique
alors je vais pas tout vous faire là
mais il se trouve que en fait on m'a
déjà posé cette question je me suis dit
que j'allais écrire un billet de blog
pour répondre à cette question et parler
de de tous c'est à dire comment je fais
la recherche quel matos j'utilise les
trucs et astuces les logiciels etc
donc voilà je sais pas si au moment où
la vidéo va sortir le billet de blog
sera prêt mais je vous mettrai le bien
quelque part où je vous explique absolu
de ventes ou des coulisses as tu un
texte quand tu tournes des vidéos tu
arrives à faire des monologues
très peu de montage c'est quoi le secret
un prompteur la science infuse alors
c'est bien de tout ça dans les vidéos
classiques c'est pas des longs
monologues c'est à dire que en général
j'ai pleins de coupures
certaines sont visibles toutes ne sont
pas parce qu'il peut y avoir des
animations des choses comme ça mais donc
toute la vidéo est pas enregistré d'une
seule traite
il ya des cas où j'ai enregistré d'une
seule traite notamment quand j'ai fait
les vidéos dit à chaud et où là
effectivement c'est un long monologue en
général je les ai faites sur des sujets
que je connaissais relativement bien
je m'étais quand même écrit un petit
plan à l'avance met donc non pas de pas
de prompteur c'était de c'était de
l'improvisation voilà salut je fais
partie des fans qui n'ont pas du tout
fait d'études scientifiques et qui adore
que tu mettes à leur portée des concepts
qui sans cela seraient restés pour eux
des notions totalement hermétique
ça me fait hyper plaisir quand je lis ce
genre de commentaires je dire c'est pour
ce genre de choses que l'on fait de la
vulgarisation mon but c'est de faire la
vulgarisation les chercheurs parlent de
chercheurs c'est vraiment de toucher des
gens qui autrement n'aurait peut-être
pas été touchées par ces choses là
donc ce genre de commentaire me fait
hyper plaisir continuer quels sont selon
toi les ingrédients indispensables dans
une vidéo pour rendre compréhensible des
choses aussi complexe alors les
ingrédients je dirais il ya enfin moi
j'ai un principe qui est très simple
mais qui est très compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre
c'est le fait que quand on fait de la
vulgarisation il faut se mettre à la
place de l'auditoire qu'on vise à ce
facile à dire c'est très difficile à
faire parce qu'il faut tout le temps
veiller à être sûr que ce qu'on dit va
être compréhensible qu'on va pas faire
des raccourcis qu'on va pas utiliser un
mot sur ton expliquer ce que veut dire
ce mot et c'est donc voilà c'est un
effort constant au moment où quoi
notamment l'écriture de se dire qu'est
ce qui va se passer dans la tête de
celui ou de celle qui veut qu'ils me
regardent et qui écoutent cette phrase à
ce moment là voilà c'est ça le seul et
unique secret c'est de se mettre à la
place de son auditoire et ça marche pas
que pour la vulgarisation les analogies
étant la clé de la vulgarisation
j'aimerais connaître leurs origines sont
ils le pur produit ton imagination
alors oui les analogies on en utilise
tout le temps en vulgarisation un
certain nombre que j'utilise sont des
analogies classique et puis de temps en
temps j'en trouve moi même
c'est un des moments les plus les plus
jouissifs entre guillemets au moment de
la phase d'écriture c'est quand on
arrive à trouver une analogie qui est
nouvelle qu'on n'avait pas lu avant et
qui colle parfaitement et dont on se dit
ah ouais là je vais raconter ça et là sa
part qu' faire cliquer dans leur tête
ils vont comprendre
s'avance avant le truc le plus savoureux
de vraiment trouver la bonne âme
analogie trouver la bonne porte d'entrée
voilà ça c'est vraiment passionnant
quelles limites imposture dans tes
vidéos pour les rendre plus accessibles
que tu ne te poses pas dans tes billets
allant gros il faut quand on fait la
vulgarisation il faut se fixer à un
niveau de publics cibles n'ont pas
forcément pas forcément un niveau d'âge
ou un truc comme ça mais à un niveau de
pré requis en gros quand moi je fais une
vidéo quand j'écris je me dis les gens
qui vont écouter ils ont en gros un
niveau scientifique qui correspond à peu
près à ce qu'on apprend au lycée en tout
cas des restes de lycée donc ça peut
être des gens qui sont glissés
actuellement où des gens qui ont fini le
lycée depuis très longtemps mais voilà
qu'on ait vagueresse de glisser jeu
c'est toujours un peu le même exemple
c'est à dire que je suppose que les gens
si je parle d'un gène houde adn les gens
ont une vague idée de ce que c'est si je
parle d'une force
voilà des gens les gens c'est à peu près
ce que c'est donc je pars du principe
que les gens au moins un niveau reste le
lycée et puis et puis je construit à
partir de là ça c'est pour laisser ce
que je faisais avant dans le blog et
c'est ce que je fais dans les vidéos et
du coup maintenant dans le blog je me
permets d'être un petit peu plus parfois
un peu plus violents dont kim avec des
fois de traiter certains sujets ou en
gros des fois je fais des dérivés vont
comprendre les gens qui ont fait
voilà des études supérieures en sciences
et puis d'autres vont pas forcément
apprécié tout ça donc j'essaye de rester
niveau lycée dans les dents les vidéos
et je me lâche un peu plus dans le blog
combien de temps passes-tu en moyenne
sur une vidéo et les différentes phases
recherche illustration tournage montage
alors je passe en moyenne sur une vidéo
allez une quinzaine d'heures donc c'est
pas énorme parce que je suis assez assez
organisés on va dire le recherche
écriture ça va prendre
5h 6h 7h la somme après l'ordre de
grandeur le tournage en lui-même c'est
assez rapide en général c'est juste une
heure et puis après montage illustration
à nouveau cette heure huit ans à peu
près à peu près cet ordre de grandeur
voilà au total après ça ne dépend
beaucoup des vidéos de leur longueur et
puis de la maîtrise que j'ai du sujet au
départ mais l'ordre de grandeur csat
après une quinzaine d'heures par vidéo
comment parvient-il à concilier david
youtuber qui doit prendre un temps
énorme à ta vie familiale et
professionnelle
alors ma vie que youtube heures me
prends pas tant de temps que ça parce
que voilà je vous ai dit une quinzaine
d'heures par vidéo je fais à peu près
une vidéo toutes les deux semaines
ce qui fait que j'y passe à l'est en
moyenne huit heures par semaine donc
huit heures par semaine c'est beaucoup
mais ce n'est pas très différent de gens
qui peuvent pratiquer un sport ou un
instrument un niveau à un niveau très
intense on voit la c1 c'est un loisir
prono fage mais c'est pas non plus et
puis pour enfin du coup je suis rentrée
organisé pour que pour arriver à tenir
ses timings là à la fois je prépare très
bien mes tournages les phases d'écriture
c'est qu'il joue très clair qu'est ce
que je fais à quel moment et puis je
vais aussi au minimum je vais pas passer
trois heures à faire un effet spécial
sur un plan voilà c'est j'ai pas le
temps de le faire je pense que je
consacre mon énergie à faire des trucs
plus pour lesquels on regarde les vidéos
donc j'ai pas le temps de passer du
temps à faire des sur itunes donc je
fais beaucoup de fioritures c'est pour
ça que dans un style qui peut être un
peu assez sobre on va dire je me
concentre sur l'essentiel et c'est le
moyen que j'ai trouvé pour concilier
tous quelles sont les mesures que vous
avez prises pour maximiser la portée de
vos vidéos
alors j'ai pris aucune mesure pour
maximiser la portée de mes vidéos à part
peu
être essayé de faire des bonnes vidéos
ce qui je pense j'espère reste quand
même le principe numéro un une chose que
j'ai que j'ai essayé parce que j'ai
voulu tester il ya une légende urbaine
qui dit que que l'algorithme de youtube
met plus en avant les vidéos monétisées
moi je monétise pas mes vidéos et donc
un jour quand même en bon scientifique
j'ai voulu essayer
et donc j'ai monétiser une de mes vidéos
où j'ai une vidéos monétisées je vous
laisse le chercher là qu'elle est pour
voir s'il y avait effectivement un effet
sur le nombre de vues j'ai pas vu des
faits donc voilà je m'efforce de ne pas
céder à toutes les modes qui consiste à
faire des top ou bien faire des
miniatures qui se ressemblent toutes
c'est à dire avec un gros plan d'une
tête sur un fonds est créé en jouant fin
mars voilà donc j'essaye de maximiser la
portée de mes vidéos en faisant des
bonnes vidéos
voilà j'espère que j'y arrive question
de syllabus dont je vous encourage à
aller vers la chaîne je suis assez
impressionné par la diversité des sujets
que tu traites mais surtout par le
niveau de profondeur dans lequel tu vas
à ce que tu fais appel à des experts
quand ce n'est pas tout les domaines de
prédilection alors assez peu en fait
comme je disais quand c'est pas mon
domaine de prédilection mais j'essaie de
me taper les publient scientifique il
est arrivé quand même une fois ou deux
que je demande deux fois que je pose des
questions à des gens dont je savais que
c'était plus que le domaine de recherche
soit une fois ou deux aussi j'ai fait
carrément re lire un script pour
vérifier qu'il n'y a pas de grosse
boulette mais est donc globalement
j'essaye de trouver par moi même surtout
sa lutte et vidéos sont déjà très
complète mais tu est parfois obligé de
déflorer que la surface de certains
sujets complexes pourquoi ne pas les
approfondir dans un autre format de
vidéo plus typé de cours alors oui le
problème c'est encore une fois que j'ai
pas le temps de faire les formate ce
jour là qui en plus fatalement touchera
un public beaucoup plus restreint
demandera aussi pas mal d'efforts donc
je vois là j'ai pas j'ai pas jusqu'ici
eu la volonté d'aller dans des choses
plus plus complexe plus typé cours si
jamais vous avez envie de ce genre de
vidéo il ya des choses très bien sur
youtube vous pouvez notamment les voies
la chaîne qui s'appelle sayoud son rôle
où les ajustements différents types de
vidéos avec des niveaux différents et
même s'ils voulaient des trucs le
hardcore il a une série qui s'appelle
hardcore donc voilà si voulez des choses
plus complexes plus typé cours il ya
plus de deux ans tout cas de détails
qu'il a plus en profondeur vous pouvez
allez voir c'est ryan soit role as tu
des livres scientifiques plutôt de
vulgarisation bien plus poussés à nous
conseiller en particulier alors un peu
lié à la question précédente
on est souvent des demandes pour pour
aller plus loin mais vraiment pour aller
dans profondeur vers des gens qui
veulent aller au delà de la
vulgarisation qui sont pas qu'ils sont
pas à l'université je pas quoi mais qui
ont vraiment envie de par exemple faire
la mécanique quantique vraiment
profondément
alors il ya un livre est aussi une série
de vidéos que je recommande pour ça
qu'ont été faite par léonard süskind qui
est un des papes de la théorie des
cordes et donc il a fait une série de
vidéos
je crois que c'était à standford ou à
caltech je sais plus et il a fait aussi
un livre retiré livre qui s'appelle de
tsy mety quand le minimum le minimum
théorique il y en a quelques-uns qui ont
été traduits en français
et l'objectif de ce que fait justin
c'est vraiment ça c'est de dire vous
avez vous voilà vous avez fini les
études depuis longtemps vous voulez
vraiment faire la mécanique quantique
mais voilà pas que pas la vulgarisation
rentrer dans le dur et s'adresse à ces
gens là et donc on se tape les maths et
les trucs comme ça donc c'est enfin
c'est le seul vraiment qu'il réponde à
ça après c'est pas une première de santé
a donc fait rouler ou lancer là dedans
il faut être prêt et huguet non je crois
pas mais fo demandé à mon agent
as tu eu quelques bonnes scènes de
vulgarisation à nous recommander alors
oui il y en a plein à l'aller sur le
portail de vidéos science il ya plein de
super chaîne jeu quasiment abonnés à
tout moi et il y en a je crois peut-être
une centaine donc c'est pas les bonnes
chaîne de vulgarisation qui ment voilà
je vous en recommander quelques unes
avant les gens vous en recommanderait
quelques unes après mais allez voir le
portail de vidéos science ce serait
intéressant de faire des vidéos
trimestriel des nouveautés qui ont été
trouvés dans les sciences en général
alors justement il ya quelqu'un qui fait
ça très bien c'est la chaîne il
s'appelle sciences de comptoir et donc à
une petite émission cariou dit je crois
tous les mois ou tous les deux mois qui
s'appelle le récap et il fait exactement
ça va donc aller voir le récap avec la
popularité grandissante des chaînes
éducatives à 1 on remarque l'apparition
de chaînes plus sensationnaliste voire
plus proche du spectacle de magie que la
méthode scientifique ce genre de contenu
mérite t'il vraiment faire partie de
l'écosystème éducatif de
bout est plus un divertissement
scientisme alors oui clairement sur
youtube comme à la télé il ya du
divertissement scientiste et moi je
crois que c'est pas un mal
il faut dire il ya de la place pour tous
quand on s'adresse à des gens qui ont
très très peu de contacts avec la
science c'est normal de passer par du
divertissement scientisme donc moi je
trouve ça très bien il ya c'est pas mal
c'est bien que ça existe ça va attirer
des gens il faut de tout je veux dire il
faut des choses qui soient très
rigoureuse est un peu chiante il faut
des choses qui soient très divertissante
et plus rigoureuse mais il n'y a pas un
mode de vulgarisation qui est
intrinsèquement meilleur que l'autre
tu connais arduino oui je connais réduit
nos j'adore j'ai découvert ça il ya un
an ou deux j'ai notamment beaucoup
appris grâce à une chaîne qui s'appelle
hué gallery donc je vous encourage à
tuer des youtuber que tu admires ou que
tu aimes juste pour le contenu qu'ils
proposent alors vaste question je vais
vous en citer quelques-uns peut-être
éventuellement un peu en dehors des
sciences il ya une chaîne qui s'appelle
les parasites c'est des gens qui font
des courts métrages c'est une bande de
jeunes ils sont juste incroyables ils
ont ils ont déjà pas mal d'abonnés et je
crois qu'ils ont deux cent mille abonnés
mais mais il mérite cent fois plus ils
font des courts métrages absolument
hallucinant de qualité de scénarios etc
donc si vous connaissez pas les
parasites aller voir les parasites sinon
dans les dents les youtube heures que
j'admire jeu peut réciter link the sun
par exemple je trouve que ce qui fait
notamment que les points culture est un
truc de dingue je repense notamment à
son épisode sur la musique classique il
fait 30 minutes sur la musique classique
je pas qu'à un million de vues je me dis
de l'impact de cette vidéo sur la
promotion de la musique classique et un
truc qui dépasse tout ce qui a pu être
fait par ailleurs et je trouve ça je
trouve ça franchement face sinon je
trouve je trouve absolument génial qu'il
ait fait ça sinon un autre exemple
anglophone cette fois c'est pareil d'une
chaîne qui est pas du tout reconnu à sa
juste valeur c'est à capella size
c'est quelqu'un qui s'amuse à faire des
vidéos
enfin des chansons sur la science en a
capella en reprenant des thèmes de
chansons existantes et c'est un truc de
malade
donc voilà vous pouvez aller voir
bohemian gravity qui parle de qui est
fait sur l'air de bohemian rhapsody il
faut aller voir ce qu'il a fait
récemment sur chris peur casse neuf ou
bien sûr elle s'est développée de time
voilà est ce que les scientifiques de
métiers sont eux aussi soumis aux biais
cognitifs de notre crétin de cerveau
alors oui malheureusement c'est pas
parce qu'on connaît les biais cognitif
qu'on arrive à s'en prémunir tout le
temps mais mais c'est toujours
intéressant de temps en temps de se
poser la question se dire est ce que je
suis pas en train de favoriser ma propre
hypothèse parce qu'elle me plaît et
c'est malheureusement des scientifiques
sont aussi soumis à sa qui est le la
scientifique que tu admires le plus et
pourquoi
quel est le scientifique qui t'a le plus
marqué ou inspirés et pourquoi pas une
question un peu différente parce que ça
fait plutôt référence à des gens que
j'ai pu j'ai pu rencontrer lors ya un
scientifique qui m'a quand même pas mal
marqué dans mon orientation en tout cas
qui est carlo rovelli c'est donc un des
fondateurs de la gravité quantique à
boucles qu'était mon sujet de thèse est
en fait avant de commencer ma thèse j'ai
commencé à lire dès je le connaissais
pas j'ai commencé à lire des articles de
lui l fasciné par sa manière de raconter
les choses
et est ce que la démarche qui proposait
et donc voilà c'est notamment ça qui m'a
complètement attiré vers la gravité
quantique à boucles
j'ai pas fait ma thèse avec lui mais
j'ai fait mon stage de débat à l'époque
avec lui et puis voilà régulièrement
travailler ensemble et c'est comment
quelqu'un qui m'a beaucoup inspiré
quelle est ta physicienne préféré alors
je dirais en tout cas dans les
découvertes les plus fascinants de fer
par des physiciens elle dirait henrietta
levitte qui a démontré notamment le lien
qui existerait entre la luminosité et
puis la période d'oscillation de
certaines étoiles variables et c'est un
truc absolument fondamental parce que
c'est ça qui nous permet de mesurer les
distances dans l'univers si ça qui nous
permet de dire voilà tu es les toilettes
at elle distance ou tel ou tel galaxy et
c'est donc c'est un truc essentiel dans
l'astronomie d'aujourd'hui et voilà
c'est elle qui l'a qui a mis en évidence
cette relation pour la première fois
donc
découverte une découverte fabuleuse tu
préfères les maths ou la physique
c'est très différent quand même
physicien à la base mais j'aime bien les
matchs j'aime bien les bacs pour le pour
le jeu de l'esprit mais aussi parce que
c'est utile en physique c'est on peut
comparer ça par exemple à un sport et
puis au fait que pour pratiquer un sport
il faut de la musculation de l'endurance
etc voilà les mac c'est un outil qui
permet d'être meilleur dans le sport le
vrai sport qui a le physique je me
demandais quel était ton théorème
préférées or ben ça je ne sais pas mais
j'avais fait une vidéo sur le terme des
quatre couleurs c'est quand même
probablement un des plus fascinants
quelle est la formule mathématique qui
te fascine le plus alors formules
mathématiques je ne sais pas quelques
formules qui sont liées notamment à py
qui sont toujours assez fascinante je
vais pas vous citer une formule de
physique plutôt ccr r en fait c'est le
lagrangien de la relativité générale en
fait je veux pas rentrer dans les
détails mais en en physique théorique
souvent pour définir le contenu d'une
théorie qu'il faut donner ce qu'on
appelle son lagrangien il faut aller
lagrangien peuvent être très compliqué
la grange et à la physique des
particules et affreusement compliquée et
le lagrangien de la relativité générale
c'est juste r le scanner de richie pour
ceux qui connaissent que penses tu des
noms d'universitaires qui affirme avoir
résolu des problèmes comme l'hypothèse
de riemann la recherche indépendante et
autodidacte est elle néfaste
alors donc globalement n'est pas néfaste
l'expérience prouve que 99% du temps ces
autodidactes en fait se plante il ya un
contre exemple assez joli il n'ya pas
longtemps j'en ai parlé dans ma vidéo
sur les nombres premiers par le père
d'un autodidacte dont on parle de
quelqu'un qui était complètement hors du
système de recherche qui a fait donc une
avancée essentielle concernant certaines
variantes de la conjecture des nombres
premiers jumeaux est l'exemple est
intéressant parce que la communauté
mathématique a très vite reconnu ce
qu'il avait fait il n'y a pas eu une
phase de contestation non non c'est pas
un mec du système et tout donc quand les
mecs qui sont pas dans le système écrire
des trucs qui sont pas des conneries le
système a vite fait de d'accepter ça
donc voilà tous les scientifiques pseudo
scientifiques indépendants qui démonte
des trucs sur einstein s'était trompé
machin malheureusement en général
c'est des conneries que tu prendre cinq
secondes de ta vidéo fac pour clairement
dire à tous que les travaux de nassim
haramain égale bullshit
eh bien oui les travaux de nassim
haramain légal bullshit en tout cas ce
qu'il a pu produire jusqu ici exemple
voilà deux physiciens pseudo physicien
indépendant qui prétend avoir démontré
des trucs mais qui tiennent pas du tout
la route
donc oui je sais il est assez populaire
mais à l'heure actuelle non c'est pas la
science je suis en terminale es
passionné par les maths et la physique
j'aimerais faire de la recherche que
faire et vous alors pour faire de la
recherche pour en faire son métier
donc il faut passer par un doctorat une
thèse alors il ya plusieurs moyens
d'arriver jusqu'au doctorat il ya
essentiellement deux voies on va dire la
voie classique c'est de faire un cursus
universitaire donc après le bac de faire
maintenant licence master et ensuite
ensuite le doctorat et puis il ya une
voie alternative qui consiste à faire
plutôt une prépa et puis une école
d'ingénieurs et qui a récupéré un master
en dernière année d'école d'ingénieur
les deux solutions ont leurs avantages
et leurs inconvénients
la voie purement universitaire
l'avantagé c'est qu'elle mène vraiment
elle est faite pour mener au doctorat
elle a un inconvénient c'est que si
jamais on se plante c'est un peu plus
difficile de retomber sur ses pattes
alors c'est plus facile avec un diplôme
d'ingénieur l'inconvénient de la voix
ingénieurs ces cas la tendance à nous
amener vers des choses qui sont
différentes de celles du dr voilà si
vous êtes dans cette situation
regardez bien quelles sont les écoles
d'ingénieurs qui ont tendance à former
des gens au doctorat il y en a qui en
forment presque pas à d'autres qui en
forment un certain nombre de conseils
gratuits comme études à quelqu un
passionné de physique qui veut devenir
ans chercheur en physique fondamentale
ben voila j'ai donné juste avant le type
de parcours qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
suivre lors des conseils
bah c'est un domaine qui est très très
très très compétitif avec très peu de
places juste pour vous donner quand même
un ordre de grandeur
l'année où j'ai fini ma thèse
le nombre de postes disponibles au cnrs
dans mon domaine
il y avait deux postes disponibles et il
y avait plus de 110 candidats je crois
donc voilà il faut savoir que les
probabilités de succès sont vraiment
sont vraiment très très faible donc un
conseil essentiel quand on veut se
lancer dans ce genre de parcours c'est
d'avoir un plan b voilà on sait que tu
as une thèse en physique théorique mais
aujourd'hui de fait la recherche
appliquée qu'est ce qui t'a poussé à ne
pas poursuivre dans la voie de la
recherche fondamentale
ben voilà c'est ce que je viens de vous
raconter les probabilités de succès sont
très faibles et donc une fois que j'ai
eu fini ma thèse le j'avais quasiment
aucune chance de choper un job il aurait
fallu que j'enchaîne donc ce qu'on
appelle des post doc qui sont en gros
des cdd ça peut durer des années souvent
à l'étranger et c'est donc sur le plan
personnel c'est un truc un peu difficile
et voilà où j'avais envie d'arrêter les
frais de chercher un emploi stable
que penses tu de la recherche
scientifique en france alors ça peut
vouloir dire plein de choses cette
question alors la recherche scientifique
en france est quand même globalement
d'un très bon niveau surtout dans
certaines disciplines
ce qui m'attriste c'est qu'elle est peu
considérée
enfin voila moi je les bienvenus parce
qu'en plus j'ai passé du temps aux états
unis où là c'est complètement différent
parce que parce que la recherche est un
truc qui est qui et prestigieux alors
c'est pas tellement précises mais c'est
le fait que c'est quelque chose qui la
considération dans la société
alors qu'en france en france la
recherche est pas très très valorisé je
pense que ça a plein de conséquence un
peu néfastes interne un chercheur qui
cherche on en trouve mais des chercheurs
qui trouvent on en cherche à la exemple
parfait de ce que je viens de dire je
pense que cette phrase précisément
représentent à elles seules 50% des
raisons pour lesquelles
on considère pas la recherche en france
que les chercheurs sont un sujet de
moquerie et c'est ça je trouve ça grave
parce que je pense qu'une société qui
méprise la recherche du coup va finir
par atteindre c'est à la fois ses
compétences scientifiques sa technologie
ses innovations et à terme tout ça tout
ça c'est la perte au niveau tout
simplement même des emplois et voilà et
je pense que cette phrase précisément
est une des causes de ce du fait qu'on
ne considère pas le large de la
recherche et les chercheurs donc j'en
veux beaucoup à ceux qui disent cette
ration suis désolé voilà c'est terminé
merci à tous ceux qui ont suivi cette
longue effectué jusqu'au bout et on se
retrouve bientôt pour des vrais vidéo
cette fois
il